did he get bricked up watching that
[ __ ] little nos x video did he get
bricked up or did i
did he uh i don't know i didn't ask him
but
uh i would certainly break the [ __ ] up
watching that [ __ ] dude
build a house bro yeah dude i love that
dude
amazing video say what amazing video it
was good yeah did you watch the whole
thing yeah i didn't watch the whole
thing
really yeah i did not even homophobe
yeah i'm homophobic dude i'm homophobic
for not watching the whole video
no i watched jack harlow's verse that
she was fire and i watched them naked in
the bathroom swanging dangans
swinging dang yeah yeah yeah he's
swanging dangers bro it was crazy out
there
yeah he's an innovator though he really
is i've never seen a naked
choreographed group dance yeah yeah i
mean i don't yeah i don't know if that's
why he's so innovative
but he is most group dancing he's like
almost naked but uh
but i think he's absolutely brilliant
because like he's used
outrage marketing perfectly because he's
on the right side of it yeah yeah so
like
outrage marketing is the most effective
type of marketing it brings you the top
the fastest right you galvanize groups
of people
but you just got to hope that the
outrage against you doesn't
position you in a way that you don't
want to be positioned right so like
clearly he's in the good graces
of uh the people who um i don't want to
say like are on the right side of
history but
like he's basically going hey i'm gay
and then there are people absolutely
furious about it
and they're trying to fold it into like
religious context we're like well i
don't care he's gay but like
that satan's stuff has got to stop yeah
and it's like [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
up
where's this energy when hellboy come
out when hellboy 2 comes out i don't see
you at the movie theater picking it
i don't see you doing instagram videos
my kids are going to see this movie they
have a show on abc called lucifer
no yeah no issue with that the number
one show on netflix isn't it yeah
yeah they posted the old seasons on
netflix that [ __ ] blew the [ __ ] up so
it's like cut that [ __ ] out
you know it's a smoke screen to just
make to be angry at this guy for
basically being gay
you know what it is and uh he's used
their outrage to propel his [ __ ] to the
top and it's [ __ ] brilliant yeah i
thought he did a good job with like
trying to leverage the sneaker thing
into into the jail thing like he turned
that controversy knew that there was a
lawsuit happening
didn't let the lawsuit like get him off
so he was like oh i'm gonna make tick
tocks
leading up into it that all go viral
that leads to the video like
just strategically has just worked so
he's he's it's just great and he's right
he's on the right side the outrage is
wrong
like a lot of times there's outrage with
grey area you know if we want to do like
uh offensive jokes right
there are gonna be people saying that uh
our jokes are just um
a veil for racism or sexism that we
actually really feel racist and sexist
and that's what these jokes are there
for
so now we get positioned as like racist
or sexist or homophobic or whatever it
is
and then we have to push back against
that but the conversation is convoluted
but these people just like being gay is
wrong
yeah and he's like no it's fun
right so it's like there's no push back
to his side whatsoever
yeah unless you hate gay people and now
in 2021
the [ __ ] is wrong with you for saying
you hate gay people yeah it's genius i'm
curious to know what his next pivot is
though
because like eventually i think he's
gonna realize like okay this thing is
not getting as much outrage as it
normally gets
yes so like he'll go at some award show
and like kiss a guy and it'll be like
all right this is not getting the
reaction
and so i'm wondering if he's going to
try to pivot
like the way lady gaga pivoted where she
was like this outrageous
icon like a gay icon also that then
got into like serious acting and got
into like more like
artsy stuff and moved away from like the
outrageous thing yeah i'm curious if he
gets into like movies or tv
and like if yeah it'll be yeah i think
he just goes mainstream enough that he
doesn't need the outrage it's it's
tricky when you're a gay dude
and uh i don't know what part of the
episode this is in right now but we'll
probably have this conversation either
before and this is sounding redundant or
after and you'll understand why in a
second
uh or in a few minutes but like as a gay
dude
what often happens is like people can't
make that transition like a gay guy
doesn't play a straight guy in movies
right like uh
neil patrick harris was on like one of
the most successful sitcoms
right comes out of the closet and then
he's got to be like weird things like
gay guys can play
weird characters they can play like a
like a w what is that thing uh
uh the show he was on netflix uh oh
series of unfortunate events
what is the guy's name yeah so yeah so
they'll end up playing these like
weird characters so if it is straight
it's almost like not sexualized at all
so he was a
lemony snicket a series of unfortunate
events or whatever the [ __ ] it is
and like but you won't just see him
being like a hero in a movie
it'll have to be either a gay person or
something
odd a cartoonish right you know so i
wonder what
lil nazex ends up being because he's not
going to play straight characters
and the gay characters aren't going to
be like the leads in the movie i think i
think he can play whatever
but name someone who's done it i think
he'll be the one to do it can we look up
when
neil practice harrison okay i think he
has a star power and has like
the there's a enough of a financial
incentive and like a social reckoning
that
i think he could that's possible or
whatever but also he needs to be
recognized that he would break the mold
the mold is set where that doesn't
happen
which is his thing so i think it would
be on brand for him to be like yo i want
to be a
superhero that's straight or gay or not
even like sexually ambiguous whatever
yes and that'll be a groundbreaking
thing and then he will be able to
position that
in like this socially active way with
the way he's done with everything yeah
and he's famous enough that when he
starts doing movies it's just going to
be little nazix in a movie he's not
going to be like a thespian
it's not going to matter what role he's
playing it's just oh a little nausea
is in a movie being little nas x right
you know i mean like
yeah method man can activate he method
man
if we're i guess if we're comparing
little uh little gaga
lady gaga lady gaga became a thespian
right she became like an actress
well the only member of the movie i
remember her from she played a singer
she did a good job and she acted well
but she was still a singer sure but like
she's not the type of singer that she is
right you know what i mean like like
eminem played himself even though it
wasn't eminem like it was like the same
character
whereas like this woman like lady gaga
was walking around with [ __ ] slabs of
meat all over her like being like a
weirdo
yeah and then she all of a sudden plays
like a normal person that's a singer
you know so i i would love to see that
happen for lanai's ex but it would be
something that breaks the mold yeah yeah
yeah man he
also might be too radioactive with
everything that he's done thus far
as far as like enraging the middle of
the country that like
[ __ ] him and then the movie studios
might go eh we kind of like it when the
middle of the country goes out to the
movies and watches our [ __ ]
so why are we gonna piss them off by
putting you in it for five lines in the
movie
is it worth putting him in transformers
[ __ ] no to the movie theater
it might maybe not be but i think
they're gonna have to have that
conversation yeah i could see him
breaking through
that'd be interesting he's a smart guy
that'd be interesting
you